I know what dreams as a kid I didn't
know what they were about I had wet
dreams and and I knew they were like the
best dreams I was always riding horses
in those dreams and so I almost said to
my dad I had the craziest thing happened
to me today dude every so what you're
saying though the the I'm sorry I'm
stuck on that horse thing please
and you just what I would be riding
horses
and
and then I'd have a wet dream I'd have
an orgasm like first grade through third
grade okay so I'd have wet dreams and it
was always me riding horses and then
Theo I rode a horse a full Sprint was
there anything in your butt you feel
like or it was just okay it was like a
vibration like a
[Music]
um
and then I'd be riding a horse riding a
horse and then I just I just have a wet
dream not wet dream it was just it was a
nocturnal Mission but it wasn't like
like it was just an orgasm while you
sleep but what is it like is it like I'm
gonna he's tell me like well
it's funny because I really it was just
me on a horse just riding a horse okay
and then
and then all of a sudden I'd be riding
the horse and I would my dick would be
hard I was a kid and I'd just be like
huh well and then boom it would hit and
I would wake up oh yeah like that was
[ __ ] I need to get a horse yeah I
need to get a horse ASAP Black Stallion
came out where the kid was riding on the
beach I was like luckiest kid in the
[ __ ] world I can't just ski just
blowing loads all over a horse yeah I
did and then and then I rode a horse as
an adult I rode a horse for Travel
Channel at full Sprint I wonder if I
remember this or not
um I was we were in Texas we were
running uh buff uh Buffalo through Texas
and they brought me out and they've got
me and I got real comfortable on a horse
and then the guy John I forget his last
name John was the he ran the
he ran and he was homosexual no no he
was not oh he's just [ __ ] stud he was
a stud I mean not saying that you can't
be stunning gay but like you can be a
stunting guy now there's very there's
like really I think gangster [ __ ] gay
dudes you know I mean
nowadays you can't like I think kids are
growing up with such fluidity that I
don't think they see gay the way we saw
it when they did yeah they just are like
no you fall in love with the person
um but but he this guy John said why
don't you take her and let her loose and
and I I never really ridden a horse at
full Sprint oh it is it is
dare I say better than average sex
it's way better than average sex like
great sex is hard to beat but just you
know run on the mill sex like sober
morning pound one out sex
there's a moment when you're riding a
horse so there's like three speeds okay
there's a a walk there's a gallop and
then there's a Cantor and then there's a
run
gallop's a little painful it's just like
boom boom boom boom I've done that it
really sucks and then a Cantor is like
and then when you yeah you get that
horse going there's a moment where
you and the horse become one you become
one the horse uh the energy of the horse
Takes Over your energy and dictates what
you do and there's a moment where your
body and that horse's neck are going at
the same that's me on that horse that's
my horse and you're going at the same
rate and you're [ __ ] flying
it is the purest Joy I've ever had where
I wasn't it's like a roller coaster but
but even more dangerous because you're
like and you're just smiling ear to ear
and and my hat flew off my hair is in
the wind I'm like yeah yeah I didn't
realize I was super about to get hurt
John's like slow the [ __ ] down
really yeah because I was out of control
I was completely the horse was in
control I wasn't in control and did a
horse's know to stop or keep going uh
you so you got to stop with your your
legs your legs your ass you got to put
your ass into the back of the horse so
he knows hey we're done because if he
doesn't if he feels you up in the stir
UPS he's like yeah [ __ ] let's open this
[ __ ] up this is what I was meant to do
this is my natural speed the way I drink
at airports is the way horses run yeah
that's when you see me at a full clip at
an airport and they're like another one
I go yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm in Gallup
mode baby that is where a horse [ __ ]
like I mean just [ __ ] show a horse
run into full speed it's so beautiful
and you'll see what I'm talking about
the neck does this and you get into this
symbiotic moment with your horse where
you become one it's the coolest thing to
have an animal what half a ton between
your legs
and just be this that's a that's a car
oh no they're doing a horse okay does it
make you does it give you anything okay
so that's like a that's a Cantor okay
and then do you see the way the neck
yeah kind of just look at the neck
and then you're going up the neck's
going down and then you guys meet back
up again at the same place it's almost
like it really is the best rhythmic no
feet on the ground no feet on the ground
you're just flying oh my God this is
what a horse is meant to do anything
against this is against that animal
horse man to run at full speed that's
why it's why marriage just doesn't make
sense to me at times yeah it's for not
for me because it is because I'm I'm out
to pasture I'm old horse you think so I
like to run but like my running's
internally like like last night I
started my wife is [ __ ]
yeah dude my wife and I got into that
moment into that [ __ ] are you on the
back of the bottom or what
I was on the bottom I was on the bottom
wow but she was like Leanne was playful
fun she was drunk playful fun crazy
[ __ ] and there was a moment where
you're just you're both moving at the
right time yes but like for some guys
I've had some of that before some guys
some guys men are meant to Sprint some
guys mentioned my buddy Croy he was
meant to Sprint he was meant to be out
there that's the way his brain works he
just can't stop doing sex out there with
strangers uh well yeah I mean women yeah
women that he dates I mean he's dead now
so but uh yeah yeah but because he was a
[ __ ] horse and everyone wanted him to
be a [ __ ] Pony and he was a [ __ ]
son I mean I don't know look I love the
guy I miss him a ton but some guys are
[ __ ] sprinters you know don't try to
[ __ ] I used to have a bit about it
about how women catch horses or maybe
it's misogynistic now
they catch you and then they you know
like because you just like running on
top of mountains
lightning striking and then these
settlers just staring up in the mountain
going I'm gonna get me that horse yeah
and then they come up with a bag of
carrots carrots [ __ ] and they're
like you probably heard this joke before
and they're like hey come here and
you're like I'm like blow jobs
and then when they pet you
so when you the really interesting thing
about horses
so horses like this is kind of crazy
this blew me away but horses are are out
in past like when you go when I every
morning I have to go get my horse so my
horse would be in a [ __ ] field uh-uh
and so I you have to go get your horse
and you whistle or you just go over
there hey boy hey boy and they like it
and you bring like a carrot or an apple
and he'd be like
they don't know they're getting caught
right they don't want to be caught
and he just comes over and the way you
catch a horse is you throw a rope over
his neck just throw a Rope Rope over his
neck boom he's yours my wife did that to
me just threw a rope over my neck I
didn't even know I was caught I didn't
even know it's caught next thing I got
two kids [ __ ] five mortgages
dude every so what you're saying though
the the I'm sorry I'm stuck on that
horse thing please and you just what I
would be riding horses and and then I'd
have a wet dream I'd have an orgasm like
first grade through third grade
okay I'd have wet dreams and it was
always me riding horses and then Theo I
rode a horse at full spring was there
anything in your butt you feel like I
was just
okay it was like a vibration like a
[Music]
um
and then I'd be riding a horse riding a
horse and then I just I just have a wet
dream no wet dream was just it was a
nocturnal Mission but it wasn't like it
was just an orgasm while you sleep but
what is it like is it like I'm gonna
tell me like like
[Music]
it's funny because I really it was just
me on a horse just riding a horse okay
and then and then all of a sudden I'd be
riding the horse and I would my dick
would be hard I was a kid and I'd just
be like huh well and then boom it would
hit and I would wake up oh yeah like
that was [ __ ] I need to get a horse
yeah I need to get a horse ASAP yeah the
Black Stallion came out where the kid
was riding on the beach I was like
luckiest kid in the [ __ ] world
they're blowing loads all over a horse
[Music]
and I never really ridden a horse at
full Sprint
it is it is
dare I say better than average sex it's
way better than average sex